in the last video we touched a bit on
the idea of final goods and services and
we talked about the situation in which
in the given period that we're
calculating GDP so this might be in a
given year if we're essentially starting
from scratch and we put in the labor of
the land we get the cotton the market
value of that is ten dollars at raw
cotton and then we're able to turn that
into thread with the market value of
twenty dollars and we keep going and
keeping we keep on going and going all
the way until we get the finished
product of jeans which has a market
value of fifty dollars we saw that we
saw in the last video that the
contribution to GDP will just be this
final product it will just be the $50
worth of jeans and we know its value
based on its market value what people
are willing to pay for it we would not
count all of these intermediary all of
these intermediary goods but that
probably raised a question in your head
what if all of this does not happen in a
given year what if what if the period
ends what if the year were to end right
over here
so we're thinking about GDP in a year
but we could think about GDP in a
quarter or whatever what if the period
under question ends over here so this is
period one let's call this period one
period one and then this is going to be
period two so in period one we get to
the point that we have a market value
twenty dollars worth thread and then
period two we get all the way to the
jeans so this is period two over here so
this might be one year and then this
might be the year after that well what
happened is is in period one we would
look at this good this intermediary good
that sitting in someone's inventory
someplace that's getting ready to be
used to get more finished we would use
we would say this is the contribution to
GDP this is the contribution GDP and it
would be considered an investment
because it's going to be used in the
future to produce other things so in
period one the contribution will be
twenty dollars twenty dollars and then
in period two the contribution won't be
just the value won't just be the fifty
dollars so we do get to a point that the
jeans are worth fifty dollars but so
that we haven't double counted the same
twenty dollars in both period one and
period two will subtract out what our
starting point was or
we will start will subtract out the
contribution the intermediary products
that were already counted in previous
periods or you could say well startup
will subtract out the market value of
the inputs at the beginning of that
period so you'd say $50 - $50 - the $20
and so you would get a contribution to
GDP by taking this $20 intermediary good
and turning it into a $50 final good the
contribution to GDP in period 2 would be
$30